[Music]
it is the Gateway to and from the
continent one sixth of UK trade comes
through the Port of Dover
a hundred miles of lorries by length
every single Bay rolling off and rolling
on the ferries on the short straights
crossing and straight on to the UK high
speed road network
left for the a to rights for the a 20
and being in the same single market and
customs union means that the customs
facility in the middle is tiny
just three lorries from an entire ferry
chat but internal brexit impact report
obtained by Sky News from Dover District
Council the Health Authority here
suggests that this free flow can't last
it's one thing that there appears to be
very little changing here at Dover port
it's another to obtain this internal
report that shows a council a port
Health Authority with its head in its
hands over central government's foot
dragging over the brexit negotiations
and key decisions indeed if you look at
the detail of this report it shows
pretty clearly that at this key artery
of UK European trade there appears to be
no chance of making the changes
necessary for an Odile brexit in just
eight months time there's been a lot of
focus on customs checks or not but it's
the necessary changes to food safety
checks that are a particular concern the
document questions whether it is fully
understood by governments that the ports
health authority will not have powers to
physically stop vehicles in the large
are blind as to what is entering the
port and that the layout of the port
means there is nothing to stop vehicles
leaving and that there are inadequate
facilities to inspect and store food and
no facilities to park vehicles waiting
for examination the report questions
exactly whether such checks will have to
take place in England or in France
current systems are based on juxtaposed
controls being conducted in France and
England once outside the EU such
controls may cease earlier this year Sky
News revealed that the government had
signed gagging clauses with some
companies indicating that such checks
will simply not be applied coming into
the UK in an Odile situation but it's
the other side of the channel that's the
biggest problem
according to local companies here the EU
could decide actually here's the
rulebook and this applies to you it
could be that you know every vehicle
going into Europe he's going to have
change that's the cue on the m20 in the
a2 is
into your yeah that's so even if they
say we're not gonna check anything
that's about that's what the queuing
Kalen that's that's coming in that's
stemming it so the queue here is about
whether or not Europe and forces its own
laws which it says it will be if it
enforces its laws then actually lawyers
will have to be checked and checks mean
not just cues but entire sections of the
m20 motorway in Kent newly repurposed
imagine this the government plan is to
turn all of that stretch of motorway
going to the coast all the lanes into a
giant 13 mile lorry park for thousands
of lorries then on this side of the
motorway a kind of mini motorway
contraflow system to cope with normal
traffic and the local businesses they
have been consulted say it will take
days or weeks to set this system up
rather than hours for the current
traffic mitigation measures and that can
only really be one use for that at the
highways England consultation in
Canterbury on turning Britain's main
road link to the continent into a lorry
park this is a case of don't mentioned
brexit but there are also times of
extraordinary traffic congestion caused
by periods of cross channel disruption
the borders are mentioned and operation
brock is being primed as an interim
solution for use in the weeks ahead of
brexit day from March 2019 but for how
long
the Dover council document suggests not
a few weeks or months but years the
report says that the permanent solution
will not be in place for many years
therefore the temporary traffic
management system operation brach will
be in force for some time both of those
things can't be true it can't be
successful and we need this huge 13 mile
traffic kind of pileup and disaster that
there supposedly planning for so which
is it and I've got alarm bells ringing
I'm sure the Port of Dover and all the
small businesses along that route have
as well this is a direct sale to sweeten
the finish transmission
sent to Turkey more engine components
the customer for that is in Holland this
family-run manufacturer in Kent sees
free flowing frictionless European trade
at risk if we do end up with border
checks we know from experience three
years ago how a relatively minor problem
absolutely jammed up the roads around
Ashford and around Kent so I am
extremely worried that we might find
that the roadwork road network just
becomes paralyzed and we can't get goods
in we can't get Goods out I'm begging
the government to make a decision and
make it quick in in business making no
decision paralyzes a business in
politics who seems to keep you in power
[Applause]
the Garden of England has always been
the Gateway to Europe to here they're
now having to plan for what happens
should that gate be wedged shut vital
Islam Sky News
you